the question self says sold
simultaneously however if I took that
off I just said here you go here's a
pair of equations you can know that what
you are required to do is solve this and
change the number one because what else
you do those unknowns
number two you must solve simultaneously
you have to include not just this
equation but this one because as I put
it out back in arithmetic in your
algebra if you're solving equations then
you've got some number of unknowns you
will need that number of equations to
solve that number of unknowns okay if
you have three unknowns you'll need
three equations here I have two unknowns
X and y so that's why you're going to
need both of them together okay this is
a salt simultaneous equations question
but before you can even get these guys
to interact with each other
substitution elimination whatever
clearly you're gonna have to call on
your knowledge of index laws to
manipulate these a little bit okay so
let's have a think about this have a
look at equation two
I think it's an easier one to start with
and just because this is fresh from my
mind for all of you please when you're
working with simultaneous equations say
what you're doing even though it's not
the main focus I was you guys are
working or until you angle in your AP
ones and you one of the things you were
required to do was find an amplitude and
a phase shift that octillery angle right
but if you did not show me what you were
doing and you just let stop and said oh
I don't know
are they equal to the square root of
something squared plus something else
squared you didn't show you where that
came from
guess what you got for that part a big
fat zero because you did not show the
logic and this number is already given
to you right so I can just like make up
numbers and I could say hi I don't know
let's just make R equals seven take away
five that's equal to two right that's
nothing doing anything just because you
get the right number if you do not
demonstrate the logic that's what this
is about
this equation this guy here alone own
the power of y versus X we'll just
unlock if you make sure both sides are
the same base right because then it you
can talk to each other so this already
is put in as simple forms accountable at
inside
what we do is write his own xi ^ ok now
here by a comparison of powers I can now
say same basis Y minus X has to be
negative 1 are you happy with that so
you see how it just caught on very very
basic index ability on that's why I
chose this one now you could call that
equation 3 because it's the third thing
that I need to label but I'm calling it
to a why was the amorites so that I know
it came from - if I call it 3 I lose
that information and guess what when
you're rushing it under his air pressure
do you need to know where knees come
from because what happens if I call it
equation 3 right and then don't remember
where it comes from and then said put it
back into here what will happen well
let's have a look y - x equals negative
1 so I can take that I can substitute it
into this line here I'm going to say
well why - excellent subsidy for
negative 1 and you're going to end up
with this which is true and useless
right so dirtfoot equation back into
itself the best way to avoid doing that
is label - I've dealt with the question
- now one really ok I'm going to
rearrange equation one it's not quite
ready for me just like pop that in okay
so I'm going to go rearrange one again
it's important that you say this rather
than just start doing the working
because what I'm about to say really has
nothing to do with this mind that I just
been right or joining to do okay
what what strategy wanted the guys to
something useful to you you suggested to
me we should do something I want the
basis to be the same because then I
could get rid of the basis that's the
key right so if I can get the basis to
save here then I can technically do so
what would you like me to write first
okay I can't change this to achieve
power 3 that would work just fine
because all of these are multiples of 2
behavior however I don't to just pick
any way I want to take the fastest way I
don't have to go to a base of the shoe -
why look carefully
do you notice these are already base
enough all right can I do something that
will be helpful here so so 8 right is to
the power of 2 times now figure out this
you know this is 4 right what would you
multiply this by to get 8 just look at
the power you can write this is 2 plus 1
I'm going to write it as dual times 1/2
right
do you see why too much more useful to
me because this is for over here this
thing is for and I don't want because
that's that does that make sense
then I can't bacteria to that something
that the same time up okay it's fine
this is just for right what am I going
to here / oranges wine and fortune up so
what am I going to you for to the power
of 3 on what happens when you divide
numbers at the same mix yeah after this
am I missing something I'm missing
something either just look first line
happy little things this is what I mean
when I said calculus depends so much on
indices right if your mind is all on the
industry little things like this slip
past you and you don't notice you just
trust no one is like they know what
they're doing right but usually it's not
me it's usually your own brain okay cut
what oh these are all you can do either
these like I can bring these down to
whatever base I like I'm just
illustrating think about what's quickest
doing I think this is fun I have now he
are what I had here
do you know is that same basis so I can
and you get it
yeah through that do you want to leave
that where it is or do you think there's
something I can do with this to make it
easier
are you are you happy with that the way
these are going to change it if I
multiply everything by two I'll get rid
of distractions that's a good thing is
there anything else I can think I'm not
saying buy the wrong there's lots of
ways to go to use not titled on anyone
if I multiply what my name is one what
does that achieve then you here to
another why - impact and then you also
get the victory okay now this is
interesting if I multiply this all by
negative one
I'll get this negative one here and then
I'll have these switched around which is
kind of nice however in this case it's
actually not going to be particular
think about this right if I have
negative one here and maybe one yard and
they're like cool I have two equations
and they're from different places that's
good so I combine them right you're
going to get the total of you're going
to get Y minus 3 on to X on one side and
then you're going to get Y minus X on
the other is that an agreement now the
thing is it sort of is that I didn't
need to do that to improve it I'm
actually going to leave this as one egg
right just forget about all this
industry stuff now okay the only kind of
question that matters is here and you
know just look at those if those are the
first things that I wrote down and I
said can you solve these it should be a
method to try to slap you over the face
to say look this I'm set up to this what
can you do with these two questions you
can eliminate country what's the thing
that is telling you use elimination here
look the Y's
I like lined up for you I know they're
inside different spots but what's minus
y one is plus y yeah which will by the
way achieve you see it's the same thing
here you're going to eliminate this okay
so therefore I don't mean this one
hey happy what am I going to get them
left look that what I'm going to get how
many why humming it again
good what are you going to go right I'm
adding 1 and negative 1 right is that
what you expected no let's see what
happens when we want me to put this I'm
going to subdue the X into something -
sir 11 1 by minus 0 equals so what's Y
it is interesting pretty much no one
said oh this is what I expected so how
will I know whether I'm right or not I
can I can take these guys I can put them
back we already know this will work in
equation 2 because that's where you got
it from right so where else can you put
this ok 8 ^ / 4 ^ that's 1 divided by
1/4 which I'm pretty sure so there's a
lot of things to point out you number 1
but like why couldn't you could have
just as easily have made these base 2
rather than baseball and that would have
been fun the advantage you would have
gotten if you've done that is you don't
do with fractions okay the reason why I
knew this would be fine is because I
sort of knew where the numbers are going
and I knew fractions from present us
absolutely no problem okay I wasn't
going to become a big governess secondly
we all got to here and here and has
these collective
yet I think I it's okay to go down right
you just have to know what to do
we go down and just put it in the right
spot and it works seven